uh there's one more here let me just
grab this real quick he said can
jealousy lead to violence or is it
considered
psychopathic behavior at that point no
it's not it's
it it it can lead to violence and it
could be considered psychopathic
behavior depending on how you behave
but as paul was stating earlier it's not
abnormal to feel jealousy or
rage or anger if right um you know
if the woman that you've invested in
goes outside of the relationship and
tries to cuck you
yeah absolutely and so and actually on
that
so violence was how so even even with
chimpanzees which have
bigger nuts and a lot more swimmers
and they're more promiscuous than
gorillas still
do protect their paternity and still
use violence in their tribes to get that
hierarchy
and if opposing chimpanzees comes in
they hold them down and rip his nuts off
when they take over other chimpanzee
tribes
they often kill and do infanticide on
the firstborns
guess what human beings actually do the
same thing throughout history how often
do we kill the firstborns
kill all the males right and so this is
this is violence was how even in our
polyamorous
past our little hunter-gatherer tribes
it was the most dominant men that
decided who made it with who
you know and the lower men got the
leftovers so this these hierarchies were
always determined
through violence and through alpha men
and those alpha men were executing that
violence
through the jealousy instinct which is
why it's crazy to say that the instinct
is
beta it's not now here's what happens
though in our society now
we can't just i can't just beat somebody
up until i feel better
and not go to jail right so my jealous
feelings if i execute those feelings in
a certain way
i am almost forced by society to behave
in a beta manner
or i come down on the girl i might may
protect
i might throw a gps tracker on a car
you know what i mean i might talk to
that guy or something or
you know whatever start following her
around these are like
because the betas and the tribes
couldn't beat the alphas up right
so what do they resort to these other
behaviors well because of the way
society's structured
now if we react to jealousy in
an instinctual way well we can't beat
them up so what are we left with
beta behavior so this is where we have
to be careful on our behaviors
that we don't default to because i can't
beat somebody up or whatever use
violence to control paternity
i have to you know look at my behavior
so
they don't show up as beta and that they
don't send beta signals to the woman and
to everybody else around me
you know so that's that's the thing that
we have to really worry about
but um yeah it can lead to violence for
some guys too like you know the point
he's making
as well as i mean you've seen some
people throughout
i mean especially last few years um you
know in the media nicholas cruz
um there's been a few other guys uh
who's that other dork that was making
videos on youtube
about being so handsome but he couldn't
get any girls sitting in his bmw
what the hell was his name i don't know
anyway
you guys have probably seen him but they
ended in in violence right alex
meniscian rented a van drove over people
nicholas cruz you know
oh yeah yeah you know nuts on a school
so um
that that's a product of jealousy and
yes to some degree it's guys that can
control their
emotions but that's just the um
like that's the social media or even the
mainstream media
narrative but when you actually dig into
it a little bit deeper and i did some of
this research when i was
putting together the a chapter in the
book on this but i mean nicholas
cruz was raised by a single well
not only a single mom i mean he was born
to a single mom that that
that couldn't raise him so he was given
up to adoption
to a family the father died a few years
after he was adopted by the family so he
was essentially raised by a single mom
and then she also adopted her
his other brother from a different
father say mother
and also raise another kid you know in a
single mother household
kids like this don't do that well
because they never learn how to deal
with rejection they don't have a strong
masculine male role model in the
household
so when they so when they feel anger
when they feel resentment
they basically throw what's a female
hissy fit
and they just have a spaz and you know
you see the outcome of it
right yeah that's it elliott roger there
it is roger yeah and betas can
it can be violent too you know what i
mean it's it's violence is not isolated
towards
we say alpha or beta behavior but um you
know
and that's just placeholders like when
we're saying alpha beta okay you know
the higher value a guy is obviously
sitting there and the beta is more of
the provider on the low end of the scale
right
you